so we've been given new footage from
doctor strange in a multiverse of
manners from at least t respond on tick
tock so let's break it down the first
one shot is a very very quick new shot
of doctor strange and wong walking at
the temple this is the scene where i
believe they're going to be attacked by
wonder up next we actually have some
very excited new footage of doctor
strange america chavez and wong at the
street scene where they're battling
against gangantos the first shot is of
doctor strange using more of his skills
in action the bus we have seen
previously in the other trailers where
gargantos froze the bastard strange is
actually been thrown at him in this
scene so doctor strange is using his
magic and spells to crush gagantos
forever the bus we then have a shot of
wong summoned on the sword as it cuts to
a close-up shot of gagantos we then have
a new shirt of doctor train students and
parkour it's hard to tell what type of
environment this is possibly it's inside
of a building and he's trying to get to
the upper ledge but it's hard to know
however this jump transitions to a new
shot of america chavez and doctor
strange leaping towards this platform in
the background now this looks to be the
same mysterious looking environment
we've seen in previous trailers and tv
spots next up we have more footage of
wonder inside of the mirror dimension
now the visuals of the scene is looking
really really good and i love the way
everything is shot wonder actually looks
to be a little bit worried here she's
probably wondering how am i going to get
out of this situation so she's
concentrated and worried and who knows
what move she's going to pull next so
the last of the new shots is of doctor
strange and wondered the first one of
doctor strange is a new shot of him
casting the spell which we've seen
previously but this is a new shot a new
angle now the last shot of wonder here
she is in this mysterious looking
environment but one thing i do want to
point out is her outfit is looking very
very dark in this scene but to be honest
i think it's just the lighting and that
the fact that this is filmed from a tv
using the phone so it's probably given
an illusion that it's a lot darker than
what it seems anyway that's about it for
this video but unfortunately this leaked
tv spot didn't come with any sound so
there's no new dialogue that we can
break down from the scene but
nevertheless some really really cool new
footage so hopefully they'll officially
release this tv spot very soon with that
out of the way guys if you did enjoy
this video please like and subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching